let me ask you did you ever have any
run-in with Meyer Lansky yes we stood
meet him in Florida during the 70s at
the Eden Roc hotel we used to meet him
that sounds like plural like multiple
it's not just once oh we made him a few
times there yeah we used to say every
time we went to Florida we would meet
him my uncle made Chuckie a Nick Rosen
one of his guys was there he a cancer
and it's me at that time and we were
getting them drinking shots you know he
had a handkerchief here and drinking
shots and all it was it was exciting
well he was a great guy I mean so it was
a little old man walking a little dog
little white dog I remember and he would
talk about the old days his buddy Benny
it was just exciting they had something
to do with a Monte Carlo and a casino
there they wanted to send my own there
with his wife but my uncle said no I
wonder I'm gonna go with my girlfriend
he said no no you got to go with your
wife if we send you there really yeah so
he was that discipline too so you can't
go with your girlfriend to go with you I
told him nah was it a values thing or oh
we don't want it to be public what was
his reason was I don't know but he you
know he felt like it wouldn't it's not
right
to go with your girlfriend I guess very
now how did you guys view him did you
view him as somebody that was one of the
greatest earners of all time in the way
yeah I did I did I looked up to him like
a guy I mean Meyer Lansky you write
about him you know you hear well over
him all over the world about this guy it
was amazing it was amazing just sitting
there listening to him and Mina and
shaking his hand and he's you knew the
stories that stuck with you that he told
about Van award that he told about just
said could smell or any of those guys he
just about Benny look you know how much
he liked them in the broke his heart
when he got killed but you know he can't
do what he did you know you can't rob
the cassini can't rob the mob was he as
richest everybody said he was you know I
don't know he didn't look rich to me but
who knows I mean you know I mean the
numbers they say about him is like he
had five hundred to five hundred million
two billion dollars he must have been
very very smart that's all I could say
did you ever watch him in an interview
he did with the Israeli TV back in 1971
no I want to show this to you and see
see see how see how you see this for
yourself if he was like this when he
because here he's kind of playing off
that he's just a regular guy you know
that he's not connected at all this is
the interview mr. Lansky why all the
American authorities up to you because a
newspaper man started a campaign against
me and it's snowball to such an extent
that I guess it can be stopped anymore
I was singled out for some reason they
needed an image and this has gone to an
extent where is just no vald and I don't
know how far it's going to go and when
did the it snowball thoughtfully well
actually started about 1965 when some
newspaperman wrote an article that I
have 300 million dollars well I wish I
had a million dollars
I said many more things remember I've
been said about me
they accuse me of making the president
now I don't know mr. Nixon any more than
what I read in the newspapers the
closest I ever got to him the same
amount television they claim I have 50%
of Lebanon casinos 50% of Monte Carlo
the ruse will send me to visit the
teaster on a mission now how ridiculous
can we really get this is just the gold
Bowl I say is long enough you'll get the
people to believe what do you see I
think he's smart man he's a character
man I'm saying that when he mentioned
Richard Nixon there was a story Michael
told me about [ __ ] DeCarlo who was a
at that time he was dying to cancer and
they gave Nixon what [ __ ] DeCarlo gave
them like a half million dollars to
pardon him half a million dollars to
pardon oh yeah Wow
and how how fax you you think that is
that story's been told by others oh I
don't know
check it out I guess I'm interesting
Mickey took you to sit down with Meyer
what was the reasoning for that was it
just because you were here yeah was his
nephew I was there okay you could trust
me who's me Chuckie it was our crew
Laurence why was why was myra
comfortable talking to you guys what
they'd like my uncle I mean he was
really you know my or like your uncle he
loved them
he really every time we would come there
he would come over to the eating rock
and and see him why why do you think
well he knew his reputation and my
player why I got yeah he knew guys from
New York that he know and you like that
and how did Nicky look here how did your
uncle look at him he looked up to him
admiration yeah definitely yeah okay
you really did would you question some
of the stuff like him being worth 300
million or him having fixed the
president would you say it's possible
that he could have yes it's possible I
believe that yeah oh yeah I knew he had
something to do with Monte Carlo he said
it so they wanted to send my uncle there
I mean there's some there's some real
strong stories about him that you know
maybe we'll get into another time but on
how much influence he had you know with
the businesses Cuba politics presidents
all of it
you
[Music]